hey I'm destiny lover of food and
science today we're gonna be testing out
some of the Internet's most popular
experiments all right let's get cracking
so when I think about an egg
I think delicate fragile you know real
Humpty Dumpty's bad but we don't think
about is indestructible allegedly if you
hold an egg with your full hand wrapped
around it it won't crack I don't trust
it for this experiment all you'll need
is one egg and a plastic bag simply cuz
I'm not trying to get it all over this
outfit let's go that's me
did you know that if you squeeze this
entire egg with your hand you cannot
crack it no really I know I don't that
does it kid that literally doesn't make
sense
try it shut shut up no way swear it's a
regular dad dad knowing my mind is like
literally blows according to our
research the eggs unique shape is
similar to that of an arch when squeezed
by your entire hand the pressure is
evenly distributed across the curving
lines leaving it intact this is why
chickens can sit on top of eggs without
breaking them but little chicks can
break out of the shells with their beaks
for this next experiment I'm gonna try
and get this hard-boiled egg into this
beaker without touching it magic I'll
need one pair of safety goggles a
hard-boiled egg a glass beaker or bottle
a piece of paper a lighter and a pair of
safety gloves since this is gonna be
extreme I'm gonna bring some friends in
to help me test it out and for moral
support all right Betsy you ready so I'm
so ready
you look very AP bio right now very ap
bio I trust you I trust you I'm so what
are we getting into right now so we're
gonna get this egg it's not a
hard-boiled egg
and we're gonna get it into this beaker
without touching it yeah girl oh my god
do you have faith in me sure
what happened we'll see that's what
we're here for
safety first all right we're gonna set
this bad boy on fire oh no I can't come
out who's not coming out she's in
there's no like magic not science
according to our research the flame
raises the temperature inside the bottle
this causes the air to expand which
increases the air pressure when the fire
goes out the air begins to cool lowering
the air pressure inside the bottle since
the air pressure inside is lower than
the air pressure outside the egg is
pushed into the bottle by the outside
pressure white vinegar we use it for
marinades dressing pickling vegetables
but can we use it to turn a raw egg into
a bouncy egg for this experiment all
you'll need is some white vinegar a
glass cup and an egg you'll put your egg
in your cup and give it a nice old bass
fill it all the way up and then we'll
leave it for the next 48 hours enjoy
your spa then you go to skin girl you
gonna be fabulous
all right well it's been 48 hours and
we're gonna see how this egg turn now
we're going to put this in a bowl of
water to try and clean this off it's got
all these bubbles that's gross
you can like still feel the yolk inside
though look it just feels like almost
like an exfoliant look at the wiper off
just there is our cleaned bouncy egg I'm
gonna have to bring some of my friends
in so we can test this out
it's pushy this is oddly satisfying
smells like vinegar it smells kind of
like pickles cuz it like stress ball ish
but I'm afraid what about too huh
I know where to splatter like I can drop
it on this animal
let's go from like here oh okay this is
very this is like a fun little like a
toy ricotta where's the threshold up
bounced to destroy ratio what's so forth
okay so let's start small so here's like
a baby maybe a mouse just off the ground
feel good okay let's come up to about a
little bit higher a little bit like a
pencil
you're gonna Bank not gonna break
[Laughter]
[Music]
this is weird it looks very weird so
this is what the shell is according to
our research the eggshell is made up of
calcium carbonate and the vinegar
contains acetic acid when the two are
mixed together they cause a chemical
reaction that dissolves the shell and
produces carbon dioxide
however the eggs membrane is quite
strong and remains intact after the
shell has dissolved which is why you can
bounce it if you bounce it from too high
up its membrane will split open like a
water balloon
I've had an excellent time with you all
today let us know what other food
science things you want us to try out
[Music]